how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some spider-man 3
no way home news specifically about who
the main villain
of the film is going to be now in a
movie that is pretty much
all but confirmed to be about the
multiverse and the spider-verse the only
people who haven't really confirmed it
yet are marvel and sony but that's only
a matter of time and in a movie that the
multiverse is pretty much confirmed to
be in there are going to be a lot of
villains
so many rumored for this movie that we
were beginning to wonder
if there was actually going to be a main
villain but today it seems like we have
figured out just who this
main villain is going to be and it's
going to change the mcu
as we know it so if you love marvel and
the mcu be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
videos and i'm also giving away a
captain america shield that ends this
friday so be sure to check out the
details in the description down below
now in case you missed it alfred molina
did confirm that the multiverse is
indeed going to be in spider-man no way
home
he actually said that his character doc
ock is going to be
from the sam raimi universe and where
they're going to pick off and spider-man
no way home with his character
is going to be right at that moment at
the end of spider-man 2
where he is sinking down in the water
now we all assume that he died at the
end of the movie
and so did he because when he asked
director john watts
how he's going to bring his character
back when he died director john watts
said
in this universe nobody really dies and
this
is very important to know for the main
villain because the main villain right
now is said to be
the green goblin norman osborne we have
had
plenty of leaks talking about how norman
osborn is going to be the main villain
of spider-man no way home and just
yesterday daniel rpk said that willem
dafoe
is going to be more than a cameo now at
this point in time it's unclear on
whether or not willem dafoe's character
is simply going to come back
to the mcu switch universes and become
the main villain of
our main universe or if there's going to
be another norman osborne in
our main universe and the other one's
going to come over and perhaps the two
of them could even team up
now again norman osborne from the sam
raimi universe died in the very first
spider-man
but as john watts said nobody really
dies in this universe
and one of the leaks that we've actually
heard is that the multiverse is kind of
shattering not just in
our universe but in all of the universes
many different realities are
shattering and one of the realities that
a shattering is the sam raimi universe
and what the plot league said is that
norman osborne from
the samurai universe is trying to
communicate with other
realities other universes he is hoping
to be able to escape
his reality that seems to be coming to
an end and go to a different reality
it says that he does make contact with a
norman osborne from
our universe our main timeline and
through communicating and a connection
type of device
norman osborne manages to make his way
from the sam raimi universe to our
universe
it said that he would then go on to
become the villain of the film
kind of trying to dominate the new
reality that he is in and also realizing
that there is another spider-man in this
universe
now it's also said that the norman
osborne from rmcu timeline
isn't that bad of a guy since the
realities were kind of shattering he was
kind of just looking to help help his
reality and help
other realities but he wasn't really
counting on the norman osborn from the
sam raimi universe to be so evil
it's said that he gets attacked by the
other green goblin but by the end
of the movie we find out that he
survives and this could have some pretty
big ramifications for the future of the
mcu if all of this comes true we could
have had a nice
good norman osborne who probably could
have helped a lot of people
but after the universe kind of breaking
and another norman osborn attacking him
perhaps his views might have changed a
little bit this could lead to
several crazy story lines or if they
went a different direction
norman osborne could go on to lead the
dark avengers the dark avengers have
been rumored to be coming to the mcu for
quite some time now and
recently some people like grace randolph
have said that some sources have
confirmed that the dark avengers are
indeed coming to the mcu
and in the comics norman osborne leads
the dark avengers
kind of taking on the role that tony
stark had after all they're kind of
similar
they're both genius billionaires however
norman osborne isn't exactly a playboy
but he does have the means to supply a
new avengers team with
everything that they need and after it
was revealed in the falcon and the
winter soldier
how superheroes were kind of taken care
of as in they really weren't
i mean sam couldn't even get a loan it
would be nice to have somebody like a
norman osborne to be able to supply
everything for a new avengers team even
if it is the dark avengers team however
since it is the dark avengers team
things might go south pretty quickly in
fact it would be fairly similar to what
we just saw
in the falcon and the winter soldier
with john walker john walker started out
as an outstanding person and
soldier however with each episode that
we got people kind of started to not
like him more and more
he started off as a pretty good guy but
as the show went on he started to make
some bad decisions
and this ultimately led him down a dark
path
now if you haven't seen it i won't spoil
the ending but here's how this could be
very similar to a norman osborne in the
mcu
you see right now in the mcu we don't
really have an avengers team
but we know that there is going to have
to eventually be an avengers team but we
also know that the government
is very very involved right now after
all they were the ones that named the
new captain america they designated john
walker as
captain america so it would be safe to
assume that the
government is going to name the new
avengers team and this is actually what
happens in the comics with the dark
avengers the government names norman
osborne as
head of the new avengers team they also
give him leadership over
shield and he reforms that agency into
hammer
now i don't think they'll go that far in
the mcu after all shield is no longer a
thing we have sword now
but director hayward is now out of the
picture and sword does need a new
director
and we don't really have any idea on who
that's going to be
it could be somebody like nick fury or
this could be the perfect way to
introduce norman osborne
now norman osborne in the dark avengers
team does take on the mantle of iron
patriot and he does wear iron man armor
and another thing that kind of lines up
with the mcu from the comics right now
is that norman osborne was actually kind
of a hero when it came to the scroll
threat
during that time he was actually leading
the thunderbolts team who have been
rumored to be appearing
in the mcu who i definitely hope we see
as well so norman osborne kind of goes
from
a villain to kind of a hero to somebody
who's still pretty shady
because the dark avengers aren't exactly
saints and the team members actually
consist of
some villains moonstone who is
portraying miss marvel
venom bullseye who is portraying hawkeye
and wolverine's son
dakin taking on the wolverine mantle so
i'm imagining that if
norman osborne is indeed named the head
of the new avengers team it will go
kind of like what happened with john
walker maybe he'll want to do a really
really good job at first
but as things go on his new avengers
team may
turn a little bit dark after all norman
osborne is pretty notorious for being a
villain
i'm sure the mcu would kind of keep it
the same way and if norman osborn is
indeed coming to the mcu there are
actually some connections that we could
make that could be tied to him
sharon carter was talking to somebody on
the phone in the falcon and the winter
soldier post-credits scene i won't
mention more than that
but we don't know who she was talking to
that person could indeed be norman
osborn
after all one of the specialties of his
company is kind of military-grade
weapons we also
don't really know who us agent is
working for now sure we know valentina
but who
is she working for there are clearly
some big organizations
out there in the mcu right now that we
don't know about and norman osborne
could be behind
one of them either way i definitely hope
that norman osborne is going to show up
in spiderman no way home and at this
point i don't really have any doubts
that that's going to happen
of course it's not officially confirmed
but i'm sure it'll happen and then i
hope he has a pretty big future in the
mcu as he is
a major character hopefully he goes on
to lead the dark avengers team and
hopefully a lot of secrets of the mcu
start to come out relatively soon
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos if
we find out any of those secrets i'll be
sure to let you know in the meantime let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below do you think the
green goblin would be a good villain for
spider-man no way home and do you think
norman osborne should go on to be a key
character
in the mcu let me know down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof